welche Sorte hast du Tortilla Paprika
das heißt
tortillaikantant brichante
Chips ja okay ich fange jetzt
[Musik]
an
hallöchen meine lieben Freunde und
herzlich Willkommen zu nicht trouble me
nein auch nicht Smash nein auch nicht
supercft nein es
ist
zusammenungespielt ja mein Set habe ich
mal vor nicht Monaten Runde
hochgeladen s mehr machen und deswegen
habe ich gedacht wir laufen jetzt
einfach mal so ein bisschen hier
rum steht hier
wie wie macht man das Spion ich weiß
müssen hier klicken wir müssen hier
klicken hier klick hier to spawn in okay
ich habe ein E auf Ender ein
Paper bin ich bin ich habe auch das
gleich was du hast und ich bin im Ding
gespawt ich ne mit auf warte ich auf das
wird dann lustig okay warte welche
Koordinaten bist du warte
sofort ich sollte nicht so viel SPR ich
glaub Wasserflasche ist SAS das FT so
trinken auf und Trinken ist die Zahl da
un oder so ich hab komplett vergessen
einfach warte so Moment anekung hallo
Herz willkommen zu einer kurzen special
Runde mein Set oder mein sie ja ich bin
gerade mit concrafter hier in das mein
Welt reingegangen und ich habe mir
einfach mit weil wir werden jetzt
einfach was random hier
rumlaufen ja und also ich bin hier
gespawt und coners gespat ja sag mal
deine Koordinaten bitte also meine
Koordinaten sind X3 was
98 bring bitte um oder warte ich bring
mich um willst du dich umbringen nee ich
kann auch umbringen bist du der echte
nein ich bin der falsche war ein Premium
Server aber nein ich bin
Faker ja ich bring mich um hier Berg
okay ich kann m gar nicht um ich Kön
michtränken doch ja dann tränk dich eben
weil das ist
besser sonst musss ich immer von Berg
hochlaufen wir runterpringen hlaufen
runter springen se ein bisschen affig
aus ich hoffe du kommst mir irgendwie
hier in der Nähe war ihr müsst epische
Musik hier eingeblendet werden wie ich
einfach unter Wasser gehe ver du nachher
e kommt Musik wie
oder und sich unter Wasser Bo wie Epis
ich hier gehe ich ich bin episch weißt
Du nachher legt der e wier kacklieg
drüber und dann hört sich das so an so
ein funiger Song dann da
drüber Mist jetzt bin ich hier wieder in
der Halle gespawt und es ist die Hälfte
von meiner Welt nicht geladen Slash mein
Set mach einfach re auf das Schild das
müsste dann wieder gehen nicht mehr weil
genau di stelleo genau die wo mein doch
ich sehe es ne ist das hier mein Set ne
ich einfach recht irgendwo drauf weiß
nicht genau die Stelle wo mein Set ist
die sehe ich nicht mehr ich versuche
jetzt doch ich sehe es wieder so EU 1
public und
jetzt disconnect seconds log into Server
dein Spielmodus verändert okay jetzt bin
ganz oben auf de Berg ich glaube ich
springe jetzt runter bringich um dann SP
bal neu was nein vielleicht warte kurz
vi nein jetzt sag nicht du bist
runtergesprungen disconnected oh
mann warte ich join wieder ja ist ja
egal ist ja eh nur so special chillen
aber das geht voll schnell ich bin
direkt wieder drauf okay sollen wir neue
Begrüßung machen oder soll wir einfach
durchlaufen lassen ich ich ich ma das
direkt durch so ich ma das hier ganz
spontan okay okay Leute machen wir
direkt ganz spontan hier ja wo bist den
nur so special ich bin gerade bei
logging in
okayordinateips ich habe übrigens
ungarisch sehr
lecker
oha die habe ich von Abonnenten
geschickt bekommenich vegane torips Bio
Abonnenten bekommen ich bekomme alles an
Essen von
Abonnenten alles was hinter meiner Wand
wasinter meiner Wand seht ist alles
Postfach ich habstfach genau jetzt komm
auf
EU dann s ich eine Kofferbombe oder so
mach
das ein Geschenk von warte da bist du ja
ja okay jetzt wieder ich glaub wir
müssten gleichzeitig oder mit wir
drücken ein Abstand von 3 Sekunden drück
mal okay und ich bin gespaw ich bin
schon wieder mehr ich bin schon wieder
ich bin auch mehr SP immer mehr so sag
mal deine deine Dings sind meine
Koordinaten
740 wier plus 1000 no da sind zwei
leute000 okay warte dann bleib einfach
da ich ren in die Leute rein was was was
so machen ne wir rennen einfach aufer zu
oh die töten mich ich bin aber lieb ich
Box mit der Faust
kaputt was wollt ihr okay ich bin wieder
tot ich komme wieder rein ja das macht
richtig Spaß deswegen habe ich mein sie
auch damals nicht so viel aufgenommen
weil keine Ahnung die ganzen Leute du
kannst mit kein wirklich verbüen ist
alles irgendwie ein bisschen komisch
dinten sind zwei Leute die machen Team
ich will einfach mal mein sie mal
ausprobieren vielleicht ist es oh nein
Connect V Server ach Mensch umgespielt
du bist einfach ich bin wieder drauf ich
bin wieder drauf ist einfach ein
richtiger
kacknob egal sei sei es in Smash sei in
irgendwas anderem ST besoffenen Modus
drin bei mir W es ist Real Life Simon
realif ich habe ich habe ein
beschriebenes Buch da steht nichts drin
was sollte mir das sagen ich habe keine
Ahnung okay bist du jetzt noch mal zu me
ich geh Wied rein jetzt richtig
schneller Zombie läuft gerade auf mich
zu mein spaw Klick hier zu spawn in ach
ja man darf ja nicht so schnell laufen
weil dann
die hören okay also wo bin ich jetzt ich
bin jetzt 155 ich bin fast da wo ich
eben war da sind wieder glaub ich die
Leute die mich getötet haben 155 ja das
ist eigentlich gar nicht so weit we okay
ich bin plus 800 und was ist z da sind
Typen aber ich will also
160 plus Z ist 420 ja ja z sind wir fast
gleich Z 500
zuen bei X im Plusbereich rein wir
rennen bleib bei Z auf einer Linie hier
ist ein Dorf hier ist ein
Dorf s Dorf treffen ich geh das Dorf
rein dorfin aber ich ob ich so lang noch
aushalte hast du noch trinken für mich
oder so ist das hier Wasserflasche ja
habe ich ich keine
Ahnung geh we nicht ich glaube es war ja
auch damals so dass man immer irgendwo
sehen konnte ob man jetzt relativ oh ja
ich bewege mich sehr laut vor da waren
ziemlich viele Zombies hinter mir da
sind Menschen im Dorf ich hoffe die
töten mich nicht nein ich kann gerade
nicht ich nehme gerade auf bitte tötet
mich nicht bin ich hier sicher ich nehme
gerade auf was
ist
Facharbeit bin ich fertig ich muss nur
noch
[Musik]
ausdrucken ja die liegt hier von
gestern
ja ja ma ja Ja mach dir keine Sorgen ich
habe die ich muss dir außerdem erst
übermorgen
abgeben wieso wartet ihr auf die
Facharbeit ich geb dir euch morgen zum
Korrigieren wieso ist das spät das ist
überhaupt nicht spät
da kommt die einfach rein ohne irgendwie
jliche Form von Respekt zu zeigen gut wo
bist
du
Simon
hallo Simon ja ich bin hier ich bin in
der
Stadt mal Simon
ach ja warte ich GL die Leute Greif mich
nicht an ich bin mit ganz vielen leuteen
jetzt der Stadt okay sag mal genau die
Koordinaten von der Stad bitte
Koordinaten von der Stadt sind
[Musik]
100 also 94 + 500 11 also 100 + 500
100 plus 100 ja und hier ist Stadt und
ganzs ach ein Paper
ist noch mal bitte die Werte sind
Zombies noch mal bitte die
Werte
was 100 500 100 ne warte habe ich gesag
nein 100 + 500
[Musik]
100 +
500 okay dann laufe ich jetzt gerade
wieder richtig ich weiß aber nicht wann
ich da bin weil ich habe überhaupt kein
Essen oder so so ein
kleines kleines Gebäude ich habe gerade
kakaobohen gefunden cool
100 +
100 ja 100 + 100 ne 100 + 500 ach plus
egal ich bin auf Weg bei Plus 500 bin
ich
fast ich habe noch ein Schwert gefunden
und noch ein
kakaund so plus
500 bin ich da ist einer heiß
Cookie aus
wie jetzt so jetzt muss ich noch 100
Blöcke in diese Richtung da laufen ich
sehe einen Weg geht den Weg in die Stadt
ja weg geht in die Stadt ja ich bin okay
gut die Schütz mich Gott vor der bösen
vor der bösen Macht ah ich sehe das Dorf
ich sehe das Dorf das fängt bei mir da
schon langsam an geil corncrafter oh das
ist schön so mit F1 ne das ist der
Himmel bei mir immer so
komisch schön die Boxen sich die ganze
Zeit Leute schön ich bin auf
Friedhof bei mir ist doch keine
Stadt plus 100 min nein was habe ich
gesagt 100 ja okay ja ich sehe es siehst
du die Stadt ja das ist so ein Dorf ich
halt dachte plus 100 und da wä so ein
kleines Hüttchen aber ich sehe schon ich
sehe die Stadt ich se wo bist du denn
ich bin da beim Eingang da
Nein besten da sind Zombies ich habe
gedacht ich Willand töten aber dann kam
Zombie auf mich zu da sind Zombies da
ist eine Kiste sehe ich aber da komme
ich nicht hilfe was ist ich werde von
Zombies geschlagen ich wer ich werde
sterben lauf einfach lauf ich lebe ich
lebe ich le ich lebe oh Gott ich weiß
überhaupt nicht was hier los ist mann
ich will hier rein und mir die Kiste
schnappen das ist eine Kiste ich brauch
doch
Sachen i
wantive
[Musik]
pleaseon da bist du da bist du bist du
mich hat jemand geheilt mich hat jemand
mit
hier
Band W healing mir hatemand meine Wunden
verbunden cool ich habe aber nur noch
ein halb bin gleich auch tot
please nein ich ich ich ich bra nicht
sagen
okay da ist dercrafter wir haben uns
gefunden nach ungefähr 10
Minuten dafür er Belohnung einen Chip
ich habe was bringt das oh der gibt uns
essen gib mir
bitte die sind cool kennen die uns ne
die kenn uns nicht das alles Engler oder
so
us F alle von denen sind tot deswegen K
die sich so um uns könn einfach killen W
richtig asozial das sind Zombies nicht
sterben ne ne ich schaff das schon soll
sagen wenn wir ab jetzt sterben ist die
auf vorbei J okay dann müssen versuchen
zu überleben wir machen so lange bis wir
sterben okay ja okay ich versuche erstm
Sachen zu
holen aber alles schon leer das ist doof
[Musik]
ungespielt
food have food I
need need
food food I need
food SP Potion of healing habe ich jetzt
ist
[Musik]
gut aber ich kann nicht lange aufnehmen
ich kann höchstens noch 20 Minuten
okay drinkason ich muss mir mein Wasser
auffüllen hier hier habe ich noch zwei
Schwerter drin
gefunden
[Musik]
stand
stand Schwert hey der kann
deutsch geschrieben Schwert
[Musik]
Schwert spielt ist so ein deutscher
Name okay stimmt du hast recht das Ken
ich doch bestimmt das ist ein
[Musik]
Zombie auf dem Friedhof sind die die
Zombies los ja ich weiß ich muss erstmal
ein Stückchen Essen oh nein K ich B
jetzt glaube ich schon fast am Ende
meines Lebens helf mir bitte helf mir
helf mir ja lauf lauf lauf lauf ich helf
dir kein Schwert me ich habe kein
Schwert mehr ich hab kein Schwert mehr
ich versteh ich kann geben Simon wo bist
du hier Simon da ich habe dir de ein
Schwert geworfen hinter dir neben dir
da ich versteh das ganze Spielprinzip
nicht ich Brau was zu essen wir m
überleben ja und es kommen halt immer
mehr Zombies das Spielprinzip aber was
der Sinn des Spiels was müssen wir
erreichen was ist unser Ziel
überleben da schon wieder Zombie und Hal
die meisten Sachen holen und nachher
auch noch Gegenspieler töten und sich
halt so ein Team aufbauen es ist halt so
als wenn wirklich eine zombiewelle wä
ist halt angeleht an der Spiel Day und
was ist das Ziel von D ja einfach
überleben du bist halt in riesigen Welt
als W es wirklich und ist so warte ich
geb mal so Poing oh da ist ein
[Musik]
Zombie ist eisenschaufel besser als
Holzschwert das das weiß ich nicht ne
das weiß ich nicht ne tut mir leid hier
ist Apple ich Brau ich bra ein Essen
dann kann ich mich Wied heilen son ster
ich glaub die die haben sich alle Sachen
gelagert und wir nehmen das jetzt alles
so nein die Ken verschwinden sobald du
nimmst egal wir kennen Leute eh nicht
nein die Kisten sind für uns doch sind
auch für die anderen
e müssen Zombie von ihm befreien haben
uns so viel getan also so viel
geholfen au sorry ja
ich ty enger die sind immer ganz chillig
drauf ja ne ja die Deutschen würden
immer so richtig ausrasten so I know
you from Ghost sing
malust sing mal hier wie heißt das Lied
was du da gemacht hast schreib das mal
was denn
Ghost
[Musik]
ghostcraft MS Creeper MS Creeper MS
Creeper da ist zombiewelle wo ist
zombiewelle let's go out of the city
together oh das sind so viel zombiester
lauf weg lau Weg die werden sterben oder
oder überleben die das nein nein nein
schützen die jetzt al die haben uns auch
geholfen ich glaub die sind schon
verloren ist
tot der eine hat den anderen schwer
ermordet Alter der eine schlägt mich
gerade was will der wieso schlägt der
mich der hat ander auch ermordet bist
TOT nein der steckt mich aber ich lauf
gerade weg nein ich ich werde dich
schützen ich werde dich schützen lauf
weg was soll das was soll das alle gehen
auf den drauf ja er ist tot er ist to da
s aber noch Zombies ich bra
er ist
[Musik]
tot
Typ
be
bei Zombie okay wei was dann ich einfach
um mich wie bekop ichin auch to okay
Leute das war ein kleiner
einblicklich sehr komliziert sehr
komisch Komar Schre wie euch gefallen
hat schreib einf was wir
falsch so richtig Kommentar
schrees falsch gemacht haben wenn ihr
schreibt was richtig gemacht haben dann
könnt ihr überhaup keine Kommentare
schreiben ne schreib gefällt mein Set IP
steht immer in der Beschreibung wenn ihr
wollt könnt ihr auch eine positive
Bewertung da lassen und dann sehen wir
uns beim nächsten Mal wenn das Haupt
noch mal irgendwann kommt ich weiß ja
nicht ich find sehr sehr mysteriös das
Spiel ich verstehe es einfach nicht aber
schreib einach versteh es auch nicht na
gut tschüss zum nächsten Mal ciao